what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
members of the Rob core man I am so sad
that secret Empire is coming to an end
I've loved this story so far it's it's
it's so cool I mean I've been reading
comics since like 1994 90 95 something
like that maybe a little bit earlier so
it's all just kind of a give-and-take I
mean everybody who was reading this knew
that like the original Captain America
was gonna come back but it's kind of a
cool thing with this whole secret Empire
story because this is to me one of the
greatest stories involving Captain
America and evil Captain America it's
always something that I thought was
interesting because it's something that
we've never really seen before when it
came to Captain America's character on
the whole he was usually always the good
guy he was like Superman right like with
the exception of injustice you never
really saw an evil Superman with Captain
America is much the same way he was
always the good guy his personality was
switched from time to time but that was
about it it was always like a one-off or
something along those lines or someone
impersonating Captain America so that's
why this is so cool but in the last
video we had talked about how the fall
of Hydra was basically beginning about
how there were a litany of things that
were all taking place all at the same
time the character quasar who had
previously been incapacitated at the
start of secret Empire had been left
unconscious the entire time we had
talked about how in Fantastic Four
volume 1 issue number 522 quasar was
able to go toe-to-toe with Galactus and
so because of that NYX pincer drawing on
all that storytelling for Marvel
basically established quasar is the one
character who could take down the shield
this massive force field that had
surrounded earth and kept some of the
most powerful superheroes outside earth
and forced him to basically fight
against this horde of Chitauri army you
know over and over and over again but
the idea was that with quasar
effectively channeling this brief
glimpse of the power of Galactus through
the quantum bands it resulted in the
shield being taken down it's resulted in
the various superheroes who were
stranded outside of Earth Carol Danvers
Hyperion these characters just came
flowing back in and they were able to
help turn the tide of battle now the
other thing we had talked about is
something called the vanishing point and
the vanishing point was very much this
obscure thing that we didn't really know
anything about all we knew is that there
was a guy who was running around there
saying that he was Steve Rogers and by
all standards of measurement
he was the classic Steve Rogers which is
to say the version of Captain America
that we saw before the events of secret
Empire before he was turned into a Hydra
agent during Avengers standoff during
this time we
so ended up finding out that Copic the
sentient Cosmic Cube was present as well
and so what this does is answer that
question so for those of you guys who
feel a little confused about what's
taking place with this whole vanishing
point thing this will answer all of that
essentially with Steve Rogers following
Copic down this you know rabbit hole so
to speak effectively what this is is a
huge explanation on what the vanishing
point is itself in truth the vanishing
point is just a place created by the
Cosmic Cube topic and simply houses
memories that's all it is this version
of Steve Rogers is a memory of who
Captain America used to be as opposed to
who he is now and that makes sense
because remember comics a little kid and
like every little kid comic sees the
world through idealized eyes which is to
say here's how I would like the world to
be not the way the world is but the idea
here is that with Copic as a character
when she looked to Captain America and
when the Red Skull had basically asked
her to change the history of Captain
America and to make him into a Hydra
agent she did so through the eyes of a
child believing that she was genuinely
making the world a better place the
problem with this is that when her
essence was quote-unquote fragmented and
scattered throughout the world her mind
remained and watching the events unfold
watching the whole of secret Empire take
place
she basically come to the realization
that she believed she made a mistake but
with regards to the remainder of the
earth superheroes remember under the
rallying point of Sam Wilson who had
returned to his mantle as Captain
America following the events of secret
empire basically the time where he quit
this gave us superheroes a rallying
point because of this it coincides with
a capture of T'Challa now keep in mind
with Black Panther ruling over what
Conda historically speaking in Marvel
Comics wakanda's always been isolated
and this has been just as much a
position of black panther in order to
maintain his resources as it is the
traditional role of the Black Panther
lineage remember when it comes to the
origin of the whole Black Panther clan
the idea was that this giant meteor
containing vibranium just crash-landed
in Wakanda the result is that vishing
guy who I believe was the original black
panther basically prayed to the Panther
God bast in order to protect the mound
the Panther God bast gave them the
abilities to do it and turn what Conda
was built around what's known as the
great mound or this giant store of
vibranium and every single black panther
that's ever existed has served the
purpose of making sure that the great
mound is
always protected with T'Challa and with
two challahs father they looked at it as
a measure of resources if vibranium is
one of the most important metals in
existence people will pay a massive
amount of money for it and so this
became as much of a tool to bolster the
various resources of Wakanda making it
the most technologically advanced
country in the world this is how all
that worked but because of all that
Black Panther has routinely been
isolated and so during the events of
secret Empire when the Cosmic Cube
fragmented and just split all across the
world
Black Panther gained one of the shards
but instead of just immediately running
to Captain America and saying haha look
what I have you'll never get it instead
he just stayed in Wakanda and Captain
America SandForce after force after
force to try to capture the Cosmic Cube
shard from Black Panther himself and
none of it was ever successful the
result is that ultimately it took Baron
Zemo Captain America's second in command
with an army
far larger than the wakandans could
possibly withstand to finally invade the
territory take the Cosmic Cube fragment
and bring Black Panther in as a prisoner
so that's where all this basically
begins to come into play now the other
half of this are the mutants and that's
why a lot of these tie-ins were really
kind of important when it came to secret
Empire the mutants were by and large
just out there by themselves they were
in a realm called Newton and there was
basically a 3d of sorts that was struck
between Hydra and the x-men themselves
now the funny thing about this is that
this actually ties into the Captain
America a tie-in for secret Empire
itself and it's actually a cool scenario
because what it does is it deals with
the character of Sally Floyd now of
course Sally Floyd is most notable as
being a really funny er claim to fame
and the Civil War frontline stories but
she was basically a reporter then at the
end of it all sat down and asked Captain
America you were talking about fighting
on behalf of freedom and you willingly
sacrifice other superheroes lives and
once it was all said and done we're
right back where we were before so what
progress did you really make and so
because of all that because those
hard-hitting hardline questions were
being asked ultimately Sally Floyd kind
of gained a reputation as being a person
that asks the wrong kind of questions to
the wrong kinds of people now as a
journalist that's fine because her goal
was to uncover the absolute truth but in
the Captain America tie-in she was told
do not ask about the destruction of Las
Vegas she instead chose to do that and
of course as I've always said you have
the right to say anything you want to
and you also have the right to deal with
the consequences of it the result is it
Sally Floyd was thrown in prison now
during this whole questioning process
she had basically asked about the
accident about the idea that the xmin
are receiving preferential treatment now
the official answer of Captain America
as head of Hydra was that well no the
x-men are kind of out there we view them
just like anybody else they exist within
the continental United States and so
they are under hydras rule the truth was
that he had struck a back-alley deal
with Magneto basically saying hey look
you stay away I stay away and we're all
gonna be fine
now this makes perfect sense just
because it's the x-men there's some of
the most powerful beings in existence
Emma Frost by herself could probably
take out Captain America and all of his
Hydra forces all these members of the
x-men could easily band together and
take on Captain America to say nothing
of Magneto and that's the importance of
all this while all these superheroes are
out fighting while spider-man had
successfully dealt with the new superior
spider-man with the return of Doctor
Octopus this ultimately reveals the idea
that Captain America in his treaty with
Magneto had basically expected the x-men
to hand over the shard of the Cosmic
Cube if they ever came into possession
of it the fact that they didn't put
Captain America in a situation where he
basically said you are now an enemy of
Hydra now the funny thing about this is
that he says hey look I'm willing to let
bygones be bygones if you give me the
shard of the Cosmic Cube the result is
that the x-men were biding their time
they were just waiting for the chance to
strike and that's the importance of all
this is because the x-men have always
been viewed as outliers the result is
that when the x-men have the opportunity
to basically fight alongside all these
other other superheroes and essentially
say hey look we're not as much of an
outlier as you think we are they jump on
that opportunity the result is that
while Emma Frost was basically dealing
with this whole thing with Captain
America she served as a distraction the
reason why is because Captain America is
floating around in a giant ship and that
giant ship is made of metal and Magneto
controls metal and with the force of God
he brings the whole thing crashing down
also keep in mind here we have Odin's
son with the Jason Aaron run of Thor
Odin's son was unable to wield his
hammer because he didn't believe that he
was worthy of wielding his hammer
case-in-point a lot of people
about the struggles the trials and
tribulations that Odin son went through
to be able to lift his hammer he went
through all these things he's you know
hundreds if not thousands of years of
you know trials and tests and so on and
so forth and a 12 issued limited story
that was published in 2006 2007 it was
after the events of Thor Ragnarok that
detailed the origin story of how Thor
was basically able to wield his hammer
in the first place remember how it was
if Thor became worthy was never explored
in Marvel Comics all we knew is that he
had been sent to earth and forced into
the body of Donald Blake in order to
experience humbleness so he would wield
his hammer as a hero as opposed to this
bloodlust it warrior who just wanted to
get in fights all the time like a child
effectively the result was that he
gained some measure of humbleness he
went back to wielding his hammer again
and that was it that was his origin
story and it happened in one comic in
the 12 issue limited series that
revealed that he originally became
worthy because Odin sent Loki and SIF
and Odin's son on a mission to fight a
dragon they succeeded and he picked up
his hammer now force with this in mind
because Odin his son's loyalty is to the
side of good at the end he abandons the
whole idea that he doesn't believe he's
worthy to wield his hammer and instead
literally turns against all the forces
of Hydra the result of this is that he
helps to turn the tide now at the same
time we get a little bit of humor in
this story with the champions remember
they're teenagers that's really all they
are and at the end of the day they were
basically being held prisoner by
taskmaster and black ant now these guys
were never really important they were
basically the comedic relief for the
entire secret Empire event which was
kind of interesting but the idea is that
with the tide being turned with Thor you
know they they make this comment about
all men did you hear that boom it's like
yep that's the we're gonna lose boom and
so of course they turncoat on Hydra and
they basically tell the champions hey
look guys when the Avengers come make
sure they know that we let you watch TV
and that we got you milkshakes after you
cleaned your bunks now when I was
reading that I couldn't help but think
that like taskmaster and Black Ant were
like hey look guys you got to clean your
bunks I'll tell you what if you clean
them we'll take you to Shake Shack and
we'll get you stuff in there and the
champions like yeah man I really hope
that's how the whole event played out
but regardless of course the champions
are basically released by taskmaster and
Black Ant which bolsters the existing
ranks of the superheroes fighting
against Hydra and that's basically what
this says that's why in so many ways and
so
many times I've said this is what civil
war 2 should have been there's
motivation
there's Drive there's logic and reason
behind why it is the superhero community
is fighting one another and civil war -
it was just weld as inhuman says you can
see the future so we're just gonna take
it as an absolute truth why well because
the movies coming out soon and we got to
have a story called Civil War the idea
with with secret Empire is they're
fighting against what they believe to be
an oppressive regime the idea that Hydra
Captain America says he's gonna change
the world
when in reality they see that he's
making it worse now the question has to
be asked here how many lives are being
lost in this battle how many buildings
are being destroyed how many people are
losing their homes losing their
belongings are their personal things do
the ends justify the means the idea is
that again this is really more of just
setting the stage for this final battle
in the sense that dr. strange basically
brings back Jane Foster Thor because
remember in that the Free Comic Book Day
issue of secret Empire one of the things
that cthe own who was possessing the
body of skull at which dead was banished
Jane Foster Thor to another dimension
another thing that goes on here is the
idea that when it comes to Sharon Carter
she's continually being brainwashed by
dr. Fausta's that's why these little
tidbits that's why these little things
are so cool remember when it came to
Sharon Carter she was a longtime love
interest of Captain America but when he
revealed himself to be a Hydra agent she
basically ran off he was like okay look
you are not the person that I loved
don't want to have anything to do with
you but it's not like Nick Spencer sat
down and said you know what would be
cool is if a guy named dr. Foster's who
is really good at brainwashing people
brainwash you and Carter just for the
sake of historic this all goes back to
civil war during that whole thing that
dealt with that original Civil War story
the whole thing that dealt with the
first death of Captain America Sharon
Carter was the one who pulled the
trigger what we ended up learning was
that the Red Skull had won in to simply
eliminate Captain America and the whole
Civil War event allowed for him to
operate under the current because all
the superheroes were distracted with
their own inner conflicts the result is
that he basically grabbed dr. Fausta's
and then brainwashed Sharon Carter but
we didn't know that all we knew is that
when Civil War was over Captain America
was being taken for his trial he was
shot in the shoulder by crossbones and
everybody believed that he'd the
crossbones had fired a couple more shots
and it ultimately killed Captain America
in
Ruth dr. Fausta's had brainwashed Sharon
Carter so that when crossbones shot
Captain America it was a distraction
everybody started looking away they
started running they started panicking
and in the panic and the turmoil Sharon
Carter fired a couple shots into the
stomach of Captain America and was the
one that actually killed him now of
course in response to this and the
reason why this is important is because
following this event and Sharon Carter
learning the she been brainwashed and
she was the one that shot cap she began
to basically listen to the voice of dr.
Fosters over and over and over again and
build up a tolerance to his brainwashing
techniques the result is that while he's
trying to force her to basically hail
Hydra she plays along biding her time
waiting until the point with a superhero
strike she grabs that as the opportunity
to take out dr. Foster's and begin
operating on her side of the spectrum
trying to help bring down Hydra and so
what is it happening here is that with
this cosmic you being incomplete which
is to say one of the shards is still
missing
what is up happening is Captain America
Dawn's a suit of armor and with the
superheroes facing off against the
forces of Hydra with them effectively
winning all hope seems to be completely
lost when Hydra Captain America emerges
from the Capitol building with a suit of
armor powered by the Cosmic Cube meaning
he has all the powers of the cube itself
he's basically God but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end next week we will cover the
conclusion of secret Empire how it all
ends what all happens how it all comes
crumbling down but yeah guys we're gonna
go ahead and bring this video to an end
and I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you